[ÂM NHẠC]
>> Brian Holt: Tôi là Brian Holt, là nhà phát triển web chuyên nghiệp cho
khoảng 5-6 năm nay.
Trước đó là tại Reddit cho đến khoảng 18 tháng trước Gần đây
chuyển đến San Francisco từ Thành phố Salt Lake.
Mọi người ở Minnesota ở đây đều biết lạnh có nghĩa là gì,
vì vậy cuối cùng tôi đã thoát khỏi điều đó và đến San Francisco.
Nhưng vâng, hiện đang làm việc tại Netflix, rất thú vị.
Tôi làm việc trên trải nghiệm không phải thành viên, đó là
như mỗi khi bạn đăng nhập vào Netflix hoặc quản lý tài khoản của mình, tôi sẽ làm tất cả những việc đó.
Hoặc tôi thuộc nhóm những người làm công việc đó, tôi nên nói.
Nếu bạn chưa có, hãy mở liên kết này.
Tuyên bố từ chối trách nhiệm khác là tôi hơi tắc nghẽn,
vì vậy nếu tôi nói như vậy, đó là bởi vì tôi là như vậy.
Vì vậy, có, hãy mở cái này, nó sẽ đưa bạn đến trang web này.
Bạn cũng có thể mở URL đó,
điều này có vẻ dễ dàng hơn một chút để gõ lên đó.
Thật tuyệt và đây có nghĩa là một hội thảo tương tác nên
những người trong số bạn có câu hỏi, vui lòng hỏi họ khi bạn có chúng.
Chỉ cần bạn ngẩng đầu lên và tôi sẽ bảo bạn im lặng hoặc đặt một câu hỏi,
một trong hai.
Và đối với những người cuối cùng bạn xem video này sau,
hãy hỏi tôi trên Twitter, gửi email cho tôi, tất cả những thứ như vậy.
Tôi luôn sẵn sàng trả lời các câu hỏi, thật tuyệt.
Vâng, chúng ta hãy bắt đầu.
Rõ ràng là được, vậy là bốn học kỳ của khoa học máy tính.
Đó là một tiêu đề đầy tham vọng và hy vọng hầu hết các công cụ dò tìm nhảm nhí của bạn
đang đi ra ngoài và nói như thể bạn không thể làm bốn học kỳ trong sáu giờ.
Trước hết, chúng ta sẽ học bốn học kỳ và
điều khác là chúng tôi sẽ không làm sáu giờ, có lẽ sẽ lâu hơn thế.
Vì vậy, nằm ở cả hai tài khoản, nhưng hy vọng chúng tôi vẫn có thể nhận được điều gì đó hữu ích cho bạn.
Tại sao tôi viết hội thảo này.
Tôi viết nó bởi vì tôi rất thất vọng.
Ý tôi là, tôi đã viết nó ban đầu vì tôi thất vọng với quá trình phỏng vấn cho
trở thành kỹ sư.
Họ hỏi rất nhiều câu hỏi ngu ngốc, siêu thuật toán này, để
phần lớn, không thực sự áp dụng cho hầu hết công việc hàng ngày của bạn.
Ý tôi là chúng tôi đã hỏi một số người trong số họ tại Netflix vì nó thực sự áp dụng cho
một số công việc chúng tôi làm tại Netflix,
thích nhận đồ thị là điều cực kỳ quan trọng tại Netflix.
Nhưng, ví dụ, những gì tôi đã làm trên Reddit,
rất nhiều thứ hoàn toàn không liên quan đến những gì tôi đang làm và
Tuy nhiên đó là một trong những câu hỏi họ hỏi trong quá trình phỏng vấn của tôi.
Vì vậy, tất cả những gì để nói rằng lớp học này là để giúp bạn chuẩn bị cho
những kiểu phỏng vấn khủng khiếp [LAUGH].
Ngoài ra, tôi nghĩ những thứ này hữu ích
những khái niệm cần biết vì khoa học máy tính là khoa học về sự đánh đổi.
Đó rõ ràng là đơn giản hóa quá mức, nhưng
Tôi cũng nghĩ rằng điều đó nói chung đúng rằng, tôi có nên có mã dễ đọc hơn không?
Nó có nên đi nhanh hơn không?
Nó có nên mất ít bộ nhớ hơn?
Chà, câu trả lời cho câu hỏi đó là nó hoàn toàn phụ thuộc vào những gì
bạn đang làm, phải không?
Tôi sẽ nói 90% thời gian, 95% thời gian, nó phải là mã dễ đọc nhất.
Một trong những anh hùng mật mã cá nhân của tôi, người đã được dạy ở đây nhiều lần,
Kyle Simpson, nói rằng mã này nhiều hơn cho
người phải bảo trì nó hơn là cho máy tính, phải không?
Đó là giao tiếp nhiều hơn cho người đến sau bạn,
cho dù đó là chính bạn sau này hay người khác.
Và vì vậy tôi nghĩ rằng luôn luôn sai lầm ở khía cạnh của mã dễ đọc hơn.
Và hôm nay chúng ta sẽ nói về cách không viết mã có thể đọc được, phải không?
Bởi vì các thuật toán trở nên khá điên rồ.
Vì vậy, tất cả những gì cần nói là điều này hữu ích
để giúp bạn cân bằng trong đầu khi bạn bắt đầu viết
những thứ thực sự phức tạp, những thứ cần đi nhanh hơn, đại loại như vậy.
Vì vậy, một lần nữa, điều này có một chút bất lợi cho các giáo sư ngoài kia rằng
thực sự dạy các khóa học khoa học máy tính thực sự.
Đây không thực sự là bốn học kỳ mà là
đó là trước khi tôi bỏ học đại học [LAUGH].
Vì vậy, tôi cũng nên nói thêm rằng tuyên bố từ chối trách nhiệm, đó là tôi đã bỏ học đại học.
Nhưng tôi có đủ trình độ tin học để có thể dạy khóa học này, vì vậy đừng lo lắng.
Đây là những điều tôi học được trong bốn học kỳ đầu tiên về khoa học máy tính, vì vậy
đó là nguồn gốc của tiêu đề.
Nhưng nó là toàn bộ clickbait, ngay tại đó, tiêu đề clickbait.
Lớp này hữu ích nhất nếu bạn đã biết JavaScript.
Nhưng chúng ta sẽ nói về một số thứ ES6, vì tôi nghĩ chúng rất thú vị và
Tôi sẽ chỉ nói sơ qua về những thứ đó là gì.
Lớp này không phải về ES6.
Bạn nên xem một trong những khóa học rất tuyệt vời khác của Front End Master trên ES6.
Nhưng tôi sẽ giải thích ngắn gọn bất kỳ khái niệm ES6 nào mà tôi tiếp xúc.
>> Brian Holt: Và cuối cùng, bạn chỉ nên đọc cuốn sách này.
Giới thiệu về thuật toán của Corman, khó đọc nhưng liên kết trên trang web thì như vậy.
Nó hoàn toàn miễn phí, nó có trên trang web của MIT, bạn có thể lấy một bản PDF của nó.
Nhân tiện, nó rất lớn, không tải xuống bằng wifi, cuz, hoặc
nếu không thì lớp chúng ta sẽ rất buồn.
Nó chỉ là một trong những điều đó mà nó dài, nó là loại khô.
Nó là một cuốn sách giáo khoa khô khan nhưng chỉ cần đọc nó.
Tôi thề, nếu bạn chỉ đọc nó một lần, nó sẽ phục vụ bạn trong toàn bộ sự nghiệp của bạn.
Nó sẽ giúp bạn trở thành một nhà phát triển tốt hơn.
Bạn chỉ phải trả thuế và làm điều đó một lần.
Tôi đã đọc nó một vài lần, không phải gần đây, vì vậy tôi có lẽ nên làm lại.
Nhưng về cơ bản, đối với một nhà phát triển giao diện người dùng ngày nay, điều đó sẽ nhiều hơn
kiến thức nhiều hơn những gì bạn thực sự cần, nhưng nó sẽ cực kỳ hữu ích.
Nhưng đây là một nơi tốt để bắt đầu.
Điều này sẽ cho bạn thấy rằng thể dục tinh thần của các thuật toán, tôi nghĩ là thú vị.
Thật thú vị khi lập luận qua những điều này.
Họ là những câu đố, phải không?
Tôi yêu cầu bạn sắp xếp lại các con số theo những cách thú vị và nó giống như
một số loại trò chơi ô chữ thực sự tồi tệ hoặc đại loại như vậy.